jennifer lopez and ben affleck
looked happy as they cuddled up during a
date night in west hollywood
and e.t has exclusive eyewitness details
we need to control that i don't know how
that happened here's what we know after
being spotted together multiple times
over the past month
affleck and lopez made one of their most
public appearances on monday
and it was seemingly the biggest
confirmation so far
that benefer is back on we're trying to
get some
can you see if we can get in the papers
i'm trying to get
that e.t learned the date was here at
celebrity chef wolfgang puck's
restaurant
marwah located on the roof of high end
hotel
pendry west hollywood according to our
source
they looked very happy throughout the
evening and ben had his arm around j-lo
for most of the night the source added
the couple arrived together
and left together give it away but it
has a very good ending
these new details follow the pair
spending time together last week in
miami
and e.t learned from another source that
lopez was
so happy to have affleck with her in the
magic city
the source added she has been telling
her friends nice things about ben and
they're having a lot of fun together
they feel very comfortable with each
other but are also completely smitten
and it still feels like having a new
crush after all these years
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
affleck and lopez began dating in 2002
quickly followed by the couple
announcing their engagement
but in 2003 the wedding was called off
just
days before their planned ceremony in
september
they officially called off the
engagement in january 2004
but remained on friendly terms following
the split
it was my first kind of heartbreak lopez
opened up about their breakup to e.t
in 2014. yeah i mean i had like a puppy
love heartbreak when i was like 12.
you know what i mean but now i don't
really count that one it was my first
like adult heartbreak was it because it
was so
public and we wanted to know every
single thing about your relationship
well that didn't help
sorry that didn't help but um
no it was just it was just one of those
things you know i was an adult we were
about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know it was like
a tough one for me